Microservices architectures,
what does that term even mean?
>> Well, microservices is just
a architectural approach to designing
applications in a way that's modular,
easy to deploy, and scale independently.
>> But given all the benefits,
doesn't make sense for
everyone to just move to them?
>> A lot of the benefits of
the microservices design pattern
applies to any application,
even your traditional web application.
Microservices just happen to benefit
more from rapid deployments and
continuous delivery.
Microservices also push the limits
of most automation tools and
infrastructure in place
today to their limits.
>> Okay, that makes sense now.
Microservices are one of the reasons we
need advanced tools, like Kubernetes.